if this is what we're trying to
different you like this is a classic
case where like that inside function
that's really gross and it gets
confusing and you just have to have this
too much in your head to solve it and so
that's why areas are very easy I'm I got
served okay good so this is the kind of
question I encounter I'll say I I can
often do chain rule in my head I can
don't have any other board I can often
do it in my head of it's simple enough
but I know myself well enough to think
okay my chance of getting air is high
enough so i'm just going to do the
proper substitution so i'm going to say
there you eat so i choose my inside
function which is there we go okay and
to do chain rule I'll need to know the
derivative of that with respect to X ok
so just noticing that that is minus X to
the minus 1 so i'll just differentiate
it's just like a regular power power
comes out the front cancels the negative
and then the power reduces by one so far
so good once I've got that I also need Y
in terms of you so that's three to the
power of you okay so far so good so now
I'm ready to actually use channel and
hopefully not get my wires crossed okay
so I've got dy on d u times D you on DX
there's my chain tribute okay do i do
you that's just this guy so the whole
point of doing the substitution is now
that looks its own concert it's very
example just quote the result I already
know right so this in fact is 32 the you
log cream right
this is this is one of those bases where
it's not be so that's why this log term
comes along for the ride ok so I've done
the first time I put this part in which
I've already worked out that's X to the
power of months to ok now I've done all
the legwork but this is just kind of a
royal message buddy you minute which it
shouldn't have so therefore i will get
rid of the you which is right here right
so the actual derivative is ok three in
the power of minus one over rectum check
again with x log 3 times x to the power
of minus 2 ok it's still messy right i
can still make this a bit better um
through the power of minus 1 over x
that's actually on the denominator isn't
it and so is this that's also the dinner
the only game is actually on top is the
log 3 do you agree with that everything
else has a negative power on it so i
guess i would like that as x squared
three to the power of 1 over x it's
probably the way out right then i mean
if i wanted to i could get rid of the
fractional power mod 3 over x squared
that's actually the x root of three
that's kind of awkward that's weird I
don't pick an n clear advantage of this
line of dislike so yeah it's where our
internet in what form does the answer
give to you is it very different how
awful this is you okay
okay they just need the story to the
sleaze that they're put to the expert on
the denominator which is fine I mean in
my in my hair yeah I can see why they
did that because the original question
has it like that in my head I'm like if
you're getting rid of one day indexed
your might as well get rid of the other
one right but there you go that's that's
the process i'm laughing so doing chain
rule out the long way it helps to
eliminate opportunities for mistakes